good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy what is it oh my God it's
Thursday did it we're here done goodbye
see you later sayara sh [__]
it's been great have a great love you
bye it's been great love you by episode
doneand dusted
Deuces no we can't because we promised
yesterday that we would do deer toasters
today speaking of deer toasters speaking
of it it's a great time to let people
know that Claudia and I recorded a
patreon yesterday we did unburden
yourselves when we really just
unburdened ourselves with a lot of
embarrassing stories from over the years
I thought you were going to say that we
unburdened ourselves with a secret
confession and I just want to say don't
include me you're the one who feels that
way no I was saying something else oh I
thought because you said speaking of
deer toasters you know speaking of deer
toasters because we spoke of deer
toasters on unburdening yourselves
yesterday and we had like a a nice
Lively spirited chat about it so Jackie
we won't we won't spoil it and I'm not g
to have the same conversation twice but
head over to the patreon if you want to
know some admin that's going on at the
toast right now and how and how the
hosts are feeling about dear toasters
also I personally shared about five of
like my most embarrassing stories and
three of them were stories I swear I I
would take with me to the Grave the
yearbook the mattress and the flatulence
like I really thought I would never ever
tell anyone those stories but I was
feeling comfortable I shared two or
three stories that over the last few
months like have really been burdensome
and I've been feeling like I need
unburden yourselves because like the
only way I can feel better about it is
if everybody knows about it even when
they happened I was like calling
everyone just so like someone could make
me feel better right you tried to un the
burden but it didn't work it did but
also time will un your burden and it's
been a few months but still I'm
obviously not over it now I feel like
we've spoken about this on the show
before but have you ever thought have
you heard about like this thing where
you get your colors done I've heard
about it I think we should do it because
I've recently been wearing a lot of pink
and by a lot I mean I I literally have
two sweaters and I think I don't know
what it means I think this means maybe
I'm a spring and I think this might be
my color does my face look different
like more radiant to you today no I
don't feel like pink like your colors
are pink and it's colors like a physical
thing or it's like a spiritual thing no
it's like physical it's like they'll
take all these fabric swatches and like
lay them on top of you and you will
literally see like a difference in your
face based on like how the different
colors reflect off your skin tone bring
out your eyes things like that and
there's two different sets of colors
Springs and Winters I don't really know
what that entails and then once you
decide whether you're a spring or winter
you go through all the spring colors and
all the winter colors and find what
colors suit you best so that like you
know you have a big birthday party you
want to wear the color that's going to
make you most radiant yeah okay I think
we should do it okay set it up okay I'm
see if someone can come to the house
when I'm with you in Florida great love
that okay
patreon I thought when people say you
should get your colors done it's like a
mystical thing like this is your aura oh
oh oh oh I that definitely is like a
thing for special people where they're
like your aura is purple no I'm talking
about like physical no I why would not
waste my time or money someone telling
me what my internal colors are like I'm
fine yeah I feel like I know what colors
look best on me it doesn't mean I'm only
going to ever wear those colors and it's
not like the thing is at the end of the
day yeah some colors might bring out
some great qualities but like you look
the same you know what I feel like is
there a color an who watches this show I
wear different colors every day instead
of like wasting time at an appointment
can someone do a virtual one for me like
I'll pay but just like Stitch together
different episodes and see seen someone
do that before oh I've seen someone like
take stills from the episode and be like
this shade of green was not Jackie's
color she should be wearing this shade
of green okay someone do it for me but
only use like the last six months of
episodes cuz I've had the same lighting
every day you know don't use when I'm at
Jackie don't use when Jackie here like
this exact setup great so we've got a
great show like we said we have dear
toasters we have stories and describe
those stories for me in three
words very
very
sad like just not great it's so today's
like not going to be a day about the
stories so you're saying we should
continue to dilly d we
should love that I watched our episode
yesterday twice it was so joyous and
grateful great no it was so joyous and
great excuse me
and it was just we were making me giggle
like I was just who are those girls
we're funny girls we're funny gals and I
feel like we don't get enough credit for
it no we're not appreciating in our own
time so funny that you said that I was
sing this conversation with Ben
yesterday like about work stuff I forget
what I was talking about and I was
talking about the toast and he was like
you guys have such a chip on your
shoulder like the way you talk about
like your business and like the industry
I'm like no we literally do cuz nobody
respects us yeah he was like what what
are you talking about like everyone
loves you your show is huge you guys
have the biggest [__] chip on your
shoulders like you need to stop we get
no respect n and it's easy for him to
say who just woke up one day and said I
think I'll start a podcast and Hillary
Duff comes through the door and John
stos and everyone can't wait to get on
good guys and it's just easy for him to
say right like maybe if you had a
business that had failed multiple times
you would know what it's like actually
let's not forget Ben is a formerly
failed podcaster his old podcast the
schitz which those OG toaster girls who
listen just to be supportive it was one
of the biggest pieces of [__] on the
planet to the and there there were like
about a thousand girls who showed up
every week by the end it was really down
to like a thousand those girls I love
you where are you like you deserve a
medal of honor a Nobel Peace Prize a
purple heart I don't know about that
actually which one the Purple Heart all
of it for listening to a bad
podcast they deserve something for their
Fierce loyalty for sure to us like it
wasn't even to B it was to us yeah but
like you could just listen to the toast
it's enough Di and patreon so true yeah
don't feel like you have to listen to
good guys like for us
anymore yeah no you definitely don't by
the way they literally don't even need
us I feel like they're going to surpass
us I hate them no I know that's what I'm
saying yeah they're the competition tury
it's so true and they're so problematic
there're oh my gosh Good Guys Good Guys
is overp party Good Guys is over party
have you heard we need to stop talking
about them and stop saying their podcast
name on our big ass show Good Guys is
bad
guys sounds like the good guys are not
good not so good Scandal over it good
guys
documentary um so let's
chat okay let's do it I got my cabbage
in did you lay those warm leaves on your
breast not warm cold they should be cold
and when they are cold it really is so
soothing like even if the Cabbage
doesn't do what cabbage is supposed to
do it's a nice feeling pleasant
experience but the cabbage is cabbag
because when I woke up this morning and
I didn't nurse or pump at all through
the night I did not have
pain that is so exciting now paint a
visual photo for me are you wearing a
top while you're in bed are you wearing
like a robe I'm wearing my pajamas and
um a comfort bra to keep the cabbage in
place oh you're not just laying there
titties out cabbage on no why would I do
that cuz that's what I would do I just
how I was envisioning it I have the
cabbage placed in my bral that makes way
more sense way more sense and it didn't
move while I was
sleeping no but I'm also sick so if it
does start to smell I won't even know
wait you slept with it slept with did
Zach say it smelled no no one the only
person who noticed was Bruno sniffing me
this morning oh my God looking for some
cabbage that's an amazing call I'm like
so depressed that I don't have a dog
like that's why you got to come down
here turty like I know I'm actually so
excited to see Bruno and I'm going to
treat Bruno like he's my dog like I'm
going to take him for every walk every
meal I need to get back in the swing of
like what it feels like to have a dog I
totally forgot oh and I never updated
everyone about bruel dorf because yes
Brew was having some health issues Brew
was not brew when we got back from
family vacation and we gave it a few
days and he still wasn't being his
normal self and of course we took every
precaution because of what happened with
du and every thing that I was saying to
Claudia that Brew was doing she was like
Theo used to do that we really by it was
I wasn't just saying that I was like I
think he's limping cuz he tried to jump
off on the bed and he fell and now he's
hurt she was like we thought that about
Theo no he was limping and we were like
he fell off the bed yeah so took him to
the doctor ran every test that we could
and between the tests coming back two
out of three came back and they were
totally fine the third one hasn't even
come back yet but Bruno is back to
himself I'm no longer worried I should
probably just call and make sure the
enoc blood test was fine but I feel as
though if there were bad news they would
have called me you know what I'm so glad
you brought that up about like test
results and stuff I just feel like the
medicinal industry like needs to do a
better job about getting USR results
like I'm missed a call last week I got
like a throat culture cuz I thought I
had strep and the immediate like the
rapid one came back negative and they're
like we'll send it out and call you so I
missed the call and then I called them
back and they didn't pick up and I just
feel like they should have tried harder
to get in contact with me because I
forgot and then yesterday I was like
wait do I have strp so I called I like
by the way I never got those culture
results and they were like yeah you're
negative so maybe that's why they didn't
try so hard they don't try so hard if
it's not something that you absolutely
need to know so I should just find out
about the results but so Brew is back to
being old Brew I do think he was
punishing us do let me
know if the third result is white
platelets okay I'll let you know I think
he was punishing us for leaving him
behind and he was acting out and he made
mommy run up a bill of thousands of
dollars of tests just so he could get
like a little attention and love that's
what I think I don't think so because we
didn't even get to share on the to it's
like the most amazing thing ever that
happened something really devastating
that happened to me was Theo's best
friend in the world his walker his
sitter who for years he just loved moved
it was devastating like really really
devastating but he texted me he's like
just want to let you know I've moved
down to Florida and then when we were
looking for someone for brew because you
don't have like your whole setup yet you
don't have your dog friendly living you
don't have your you just found spr T I
just found a spray tan like I you got to
find new people when you move so I was
like wait maybe he lives near Jacks lo
and behold he lives like 30 minutes away
Bruno spent in amazing 3 weeks with him
in his like Community with all these
people who loved Bruno and like I
actually don't think Bruno was acting
out at all I think he had the best time
at mer oh he had a great time but he was
also sick there too so it was just a
laugh for brew and the thing about Brew
is he's Tinkerbell like if he doesn't
have attention he will die no that's not
who he is Bruno is literally like The
Boy in the Plastic Bubble Bruno goes
nowhere sees nobody like he's always in
his house that's very clean with his
Branch Basics products like he left the
house and he got sick no Bruno knows
struggle trta Bruno knows struggle
Johnny Depp Bruno knows struggle Bruno
doesn't know
Strife he knows
strice that he does Bruno works so hard
he puts the whole family on his back
he's the gloo okay I don't know if
anybody's been noticing like the extra
[__] I've been putting into toast
Instagram oh you've been doing some
stories I've been like you know making
more content posting more reals just
trying to like up our [__] on social
media
and I started a new segment on the
Instagram called YT o TD where I didn't
explicitly say what the acronym stands
for but I really felt like it was
self-explanatory everybody knows
everybody let me say everybody knows otd
is of the day so that's half the acronym
already solved for you and then using
context clues you could figure out what
the rest of the acronym stands for so
what I would do was like the YouTube
comments are so funny sometimes that
these people deserve a platform so I've
been screenshotting one a day and giving
it the award of the YouTube comment of
the day so I put a screenshot of a
YouTube comment I put YT c o t d how do
you not figure that out you just can't
you
can't raw dog an acronym you have to
post it once you post it once YouTube
comment of the day parentheses y t c o t
d and then going forward it could always
you have to do it once that's like
literally textbook I just feel like our
gen Z listeners figured it out well then
you're being biased towards gen Z
listeners and leaving everyone behind
and this business this business was
built off the backs of Millennials so
you're really going to do that no I so
love our Millennial audience I love our
Boomers as well but you know ever since
we've kind of like I said taken off on
Tik Tok our submissions for dear
toasters we've been getting like a bunch
from like literal high schoolers and we
have one today and I just feel like it
is our opportunity like I wish I could
talk to myself when I was this girl's
age cuz she's going through something
extremely relatable the boy she was
Snapchatting with like totally changed
his Vibe you know and I just think like
our advice is going to be really
important to her speaking of Snapchat
have you been seeing these
hearings you know what I have the people
who bought drugs on Snapchat so like the
heads of Snapchat and so Evan Spiegel
and Mark Zuckerberg like are having to
testify in front of the senate about
social media and like kids and um social
media bullying and then also one parent
their child was able to like buy drugs
via Snapchat and they died of an
overdose cuz it was like fentol pills
and the the person questioning Evan
Spiel was just going like so hard about
like what are you doing like do you want
to apologize to this parent and like he
seemed like extremely upset about it and
contrite and was talking about like all
the measures that they've taken and what
they do to like try and stop these
things from happening but like
Snapchat's not the reason why there's
like fentol in the country well also
it's a tough question because if he says
sorry that's almost like an admission of
guilt and like you open yourself up for
like a lawsuit oh yeah that's something
else but it's like EV Snapchat played a
role in this for sure but like what
about the fenol yeah yeah and I I I saw
people having this conversation in the
comments of a Tik Tok where Mark
Zuckerberg was being bered and there's
enormous blame to be placed on these
platforms for like the safeguards they
claim to put in place that literally
don't work it's it's really they're not
doing enough but there is also a
conversation this is what people were
saying in the comments like about I feel
like this is going to be like a hot take
but this is what people were saying at
me like about parenting like you need to
really monitor your kids activity on
social media the amount of time they
spend on social media what they're doing
on social media the access they have
like it is this this this exists these
monstrous companies they exist and
there's nothing really we can do about
it so how you protect your kids is of
Paramount importance no yes and I was
going to say also the parenting of the
people who are doing The Bullying like
where the [__] are you your kid's a
monster you've raised a monster oh my
God I just I saw another Tik Tok this
woman she was saying she's like I just
found out like my kids's the bully
what sort of bullying I don't know
there's there are varying degrees of
bullying and I think also the word bully
has become like somebody said something
that I disagree with or that's like
constructive you're a bully they're I'm
talking about like true bullying like
physical violence verbal violence yeah
totally I don't know what kind of bully
I think it was like you know shoving
into lockers like old school there yeah
but the bullying has just like reached
New Heights and it has I feel like I was
seeing mark Berg there was a kid from
Chicago
um and he committed suicide cuz he was
being bullied on Facebook I and I I
remember when the story came out I'm
just trying to see if it was the same
child but I'm pretty sure this kid
killed himself because people at his
school were saying that he's
unvaccinated yeah and that comes yeah
cuz I remember that story came out like
a few years ago someone a kid in Chicago
like committed suicide he was being
bulleted at school cuz kids were saying
that he's unvaccinated and I think at
the whole time he was vaccinated anyway
but like that comes from that's so weird
that comes from the parents for sure for
sure and that's what I mean like
parenting yeah no there is uh a big
conversation to be had about the
platforms but there's also an equally
large conversation to be had about like
what kind of people are we raising and
how are we raising them like some people
are animals yeah and it's not you know
not every child who acts out it's a
direct result of like their parents but
like no no but if you know that your
child is a monster like take away their
phone it's on it's on you to put them in
some sort of like facility for troubled
youth no for real yeah and not give them
access to bully unfettered but there is
also because of social media kids are so
[__] secretive and private it's
entirely possible that there are like
these monstrous kids whose parents think
they're like amazing like kids can be
like really duplicitous and evil but
just as the kids have access to social
media like the parents should be able to
see what their kids are doing
a
th% like get in there I like in that by
the way that's literally that whole
story line of Alice in working moms like
her kid is insane and she only finds out
because she found her Fina and made a
Fina and like followed her but
um I really hope by the time my kids are
like 11 12 13 there is like something
you know in place but if not like I'm
going to choose a school where like me
and all the moms get together and we say
like no phones yeah cuz if all the kids
have phones and your kid does like then
your kid's a loser and you don't want
your kid to be a loser a it and then
it's going to be this thing it's very
hard flip phones like we were do you
know how happy we were with our flip
phones and our like four text messages a
day snake even brick breaker like it was
so simple yeah Simple Times love let's
go back to that yeah stop it's so sad so
yes I have been seeing those hearings
and actually I wasn't really paying
attention but now I will yeah and I just
I've been trying to figure out if it's
the same boy with the unvaccinated
bullying and that's what this is so
parents that comes from you his par his
parents are at the hearings yeah they
they spoke to Mark Zuckerberg oh damn
yeah but then the Evan speak one was the
the drugs
one yes yes yes so while social media is
like a vessel for which people can carry
out bullying like there are a lot of
steps and people that can stop it along
the way yeah it starts at
home because sadly like I think what you
realize is like the world ain't going to
protect your kid like you have to yeah
but also the parents of bullies like cuz
a 15-year-old kid doesn't get the idea
to bully someone for their vaccination
status without it coming from parents
yeah and Society yeah so like that's a
disgrace agreed and and where the fault
lies is not entirely with Mark
Zuckerberg uh that I agree with even
though the way he places his platform is
pretty shitty all the platforms are
awful
yeah so those are my thoughts those are
your thoughts I'm I think I'm ready to
get into the stories because we do still
have deer toasters true true so without
further Ado here are the fast five
stories that you need to know and the
fast five stories that you need to know
are brought to you by the new Lin skate
film scrambled scrambled is a heartfelt
yet hilarious journey of self-discovery
and self love it's written directed and
starring leam mckendrick who is quote
among Indie wire's top female filmmakers
to watch this year so the story line is
a tale as oldest time quintessential
Eternal bridesmaid Nelly Robinson who is
of course played by leam mckendrick
constantly finds herself between
weddings baby showers bad dates so when
she begins to feel like the clock is
ticking and she is faced with the Bleak
romantic prospects that she is facing
Nelly makes the brave decision to freeze
her eggs setting her on an empowering
Journey To A Brave New World where she
ultimately discovers that the one she's
looking for
you guessed it might just be herself so
film threat says this movie is brilliant
storytelling you can learn more about
the movie about Leah and of course watch
the trailer which I loved at
lionsgate.com
movc scrambled now scrambled is
obviously play on words cuz she's
freezing her eggs but she's also she's
kind of in this sort of chaotic phase of
her life if you will so in theaters
February 2nd the movie is called
scrambled it is the new lion gate film
it is rated R so you can go to
lionsgate.com
movs scrambled to learn more about the
movie watch the trailer it is in
theaters February second and it is rated
R today's episode is also brought to you
by the farmer's dog this new year the
easiest healthy Habit to start is one
for your dog can't do it for yourself do
it for your dog the farmer's dog makes
feeding real healthy dog food easy and
convenient and your dog will absolutely
love it it is smart healthy pet food
that you can feel good about feeding
your pup that's why it's time to quit
the kibble kick the cans and start fresh
so the farmer's dog makes and delivers
fresh healthy dog food right to your
door it is developed by vets it is
nutritionally balanced and it's made
from real meat and vegetables to the
safety standards of human food so a
fresh diet for dogs has been found to
have all sorts of benefits When Theo was
here he loved his food and some of the
benefits can include a healthier coat
and skin better breath easier digestion
smaller better poops a healthy diet
isn't just important for humans and it
doesn't matter if your dog is young or
old it is always the right time to begin
investing in their health and that means
that more happy healthy and full years
together are on the horizon with you and
your dog happy for you traditional dry
andw dog food options are highly
processed they can use much lower
quality ingredients than they claim to
and they're also extremely difficult to
portion accurately so the farmer's dog
is sending you your food pre-portioned
specifically for your dog based on their
unique nutritional needs super easy to
main maintain ideal weight get 50% off
your first box of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com toast plus you get
free shipping but only when you go to
the farmers
dog.com toast to get 50% off that's
thefarmersdog.com
toast thank you it's I was just thinking
I it's so like funny to me because like
when we think of like hold
on uh oh it's
contagious oh and also I realized like
that wasn't going to be a fire point I
don't want to continue with the sentence
you go oh what was it regarding like I
don't even want to bring it up our
previous
conversation social media
yes yes but it like wasn't a good point
like a bad point or just like a lukewarm
point no like a really dumb point oh
okay well now I kind of want to know I
like it's just when we think about these
like evil like you know Mark Zuckerberg
type like I don't really include Evan
Spiegel in that and I feel like maybe
that's just wrong of me because he's
just like traditionally handsome and
Jewish like maybe that's why I think
that but I don't think of him as like
those evil Tech King you know I
understand what you mean he's definitely
separated himself from Mark Zuckerberg
like I don't know Mark Zuckerberg just
gives like alien Vibes I guess yeah no
but also Mark Zuckerberg is like a
vulture and he just like consumes and
destroys everything in his path and
these little companies he steals like
he's nefarious zuer really also like
does
control so much like Snapchat is like
this tiny corner of the internet to me
just doesn't feel like this all powerful
being Spiegel agreed right maybe it
wasn't a bad point our first story Pat
McAfee knew the girlies were hungry for
some
te and he had Travis Kelsey on his show
where they were just chitchat chatting
about funny like Travis gave more to the
Pat McAfee show in terms of Taylor than
he gave to his own podcast well I think
because Pat McAfee was prying a little
bit and Jason knows
better Jason knows better yeah you know
yeah but also like did Travis have to do
this interview no but I think people
just like popping on to the Pat McAfee
show that kind of seems to
be the vibe and also I also thought that
Pat McAfee like was team Aaron roders
and would never have Travis on his show
because Aaron goes on Pat McAfee all the
time Aaron and Travis have beef and that
beef started on the Pat McAfee show but
I guess he's kind of like this neutral
Switzerland show like everyone can come
out and start whatever sort of drama
they want to right and I do feel like
the Aaron Travis Kelsey beef is like not
so serious it's just kind of like them
taking Jabs at one another but like not
serious beef no and that's what I
learned also from watching this new
episode of new heights was that this
video had went viral before the Kansas
City Chiefs game of Travis throwing the
helmet and football of the Ravens kicker
because apparently like he was in
Patrick mahomes's way before the game
while they were training and they talked
about on the podcast Justin Tucker was
like a little butt hurt about it in his
postgame interview but it's like they
all just like kind of like spar with
each other but it's not serious like
like Travis called him a dick but I
don't like it wasn't like I don't think
they're beefing you know no they're just
being guys and I saw that video and
people being like Travis Kelsey and
Patrick Mahomes are bullies they threw
the equipment of the other guy this what
I'm saying manipulating the word bully
Claudia we're literally watching these
people tackle each other like this is a
a game where they just abuse each other
and he he threw the equipment and you're
sad and you're sad about the equipment
when I climb into bed I start feeling
sad why did Patrick throw the other
team's hat and suddenly I miss my mom
and my dad like are you joking you can't
be so soft if you're watching
football she said what she [__] said
[__] they're literally beating each
other to the ground no like I've heard
of
CTE and you're upset that his helmet got
tossed this you're in the go back to not
watching football then so what did
Travis say on Pat backa so he talks
about tayor what he said was interesting
they talked about the first game that
Taylor went to yeah and Travis said we
had known each other for close to a
month up to that point so we knew that
there was the concert at Arrowhead and
then jump to the first game together
then we knew obviously but before that
rocking the stage at Arrowhead rocking
the stage right shoot that's what I said
concert at Arrowhead no no no but then
like a few weeks in between the concert
and the football game he went on Pat
McAfee and like basically invited her
publicly we didn't know that they had
already been hanging out and that's why
we were all like okay thirsty loser well
not maybe all of us but I definitely was
like thirsty loser sit the [__] down
when he did that interview that was wide
ranging he said like him and Taylor had
been together or maybe it was her
interview whatever they said they'd been
together for a while that first game
wasn't their first time that they met
but that's how it looked to us yeah but
now we know it was a month so it still
was kind of early for them to be public
yes yes when you know you know he said
it wasn't just an out of the blue hey
come to the game that's what it looked
like though so I'm glad he cleared that
up but I also appreciate him really
helping us with the timeline like he I
don't think he like actually I do think
he understands like how important this
is to so many people and like him just
dropping context clues every interview
is enormously helpful for us like
putting for those of us like working
behind the scenes putting together the
timeline yeah and I think it was when
Olivia was on the show when she said
they've definitely been dating for so
long even before the concert and I was
like huh I don't know but now we know
like yeah and we need to know these
things so the concert was what July
the concert was July yeah football's on
in
August September the first game was in
September that she went to got it okay
so he's like we've been together for a
month so they really started in August
so they have been together for six
months almost wow that's like a real ass
relationship he also said he is not
going to the Grammys right which I think
we all like he also I'm probably not
going to the Grammys I feel like he's
waiting for maybe to get permission I
will pass away by the way I'm lowkey
excited for the Grammys do we have it as
a story no Luke Holmes is performing at
the Grammys with Tracy Chapman oh cuz
fast car is nominated right and Tracy
Chapman has not yes Tracy Chapman has
not been seen or nominated or excuse me
has not been seen or performed literally
since like 2008 like the fact that she's
coming out of the woodwork is the
biggest deal and the fact that it's for
Luke like we stand oh that's exciting I
hope Travis shouldn't go to the Grammys
I think it would like take away from
like the seriousness of the like it's a
Super Bowl you've got to ohis of the
Super Bowl yeah yeah I thought you meant
like it would overtake like her moment
no no no they're a unit now they're a
team they're a unit now also I also
don't think that this is like Taylor's
Grammy I feel like when we know certain
years when she's going to sweep this is
a very competitive year and while it was
the year of Taylor the thing she's
nominated for like I I don't think
she'll win a tonn something we need her
to win at least one so we can hear a
speech and see if she talks about him
when I got up to the podium I think that
I forgot to say your name she would
never do that to Travis but she did do
it to Calvin Harris it happens it
happens like it couldn't happen when
there's a presence in your life as large
as Travis Kelce right so I don't think
he'll be there and I I don't think that
he should be there either in a I need I
need new music from Taylor Swift in a
biblical sense because I need the
tiniest window of into what's what's
going on I totally agree anyways he was
having fun on the show Patrick momes
came in said showed his
face Good
Times cute anything else he said that
struck a chord with
you no no no but he was just being very
open he said we're two people in a
relationship supporting each other we
love cute so I'm like oh so you're in a
relationship which we knew that oh so
you love her well they do love each
other like they were saying it in the
field
that we know yeah are you ready for our
next story kind of adjacent news so
we'll switch gears okay fans call out
Britney mahomes's high horse attitude
towards a stadium employee she's just
the worst they said so fans are slamming
Britney mahon's attitude toward a
stadium employee in a viral Tik Tok
posted by CBS after the Kansas City
Chiefs game on Sunday Britney can be
seen walking with her husband Patrick
Mahomes before turning to a stadium
employee and qu quote quot rudely asking
where do we go from here as she spun her
finger in a circle everyone's saying
attitude she needs to get off her high
horse oh my God you guys it was
literally like the least I I I could
have if I hadn't known that there was
like a story behind this I would have
watched the video and moved on with my
life like it was so nothing moving her
finger in a circle like she was just
like where did we go from here like it
was so innocent he was the like one of
many people guiding them out of the
stadium you know they go through tunnels
and whatever to get to the back exit it
was so harmless it was so nothing people
really need to leave this [__] alone
like for real I saw the headline a
number of times before I was like you
know what let me watch the video and
decide for myself I'm like that's it we
didn't even like see her who she's
talking to nothing Burger nothing Burger
people go so hard against her and then
also you know then everyone comes out
and is like yeah this has been my
experience with her too I
just there's not enough there there for
me that's the thing it's like when
something like this happens for well
this is a nothing Burger story but then
people use it as a time to be like I
waited on her once and she didn't tip me
and I just don't believe that I have
heard many many stories about Travis and
Travis Patrick and Britney like going
out to dinner paying for everyone at the
restaurant's table like they're
extremely generous they lift up their
Community they invest a lot in their
Community they're extremely charitable
like I've really had enough and I don't
even particularly ride for these people
or this family but like to see someone
like constantly being being braided yeah
stop yeah I I don't and it's also like a
handful of people where that she has
interacted with thousands of people in
her life if this was really like she's
this horrible awful person like it would
be overwhelming not just like I waited
on her once and she didn't tip me like
what does that mean a zero tip a a low
tip that you don't think is high enough
for how much money he makes like right
and know also who are you are you even a
waitress like people just make [__] up
people are liars yeah I'm so over it no
and the thing with Britney M is I I have
done a bunch of research like when it
all started so the thing that really set
people off that started like a kind of a
hate train for her is she was in a suite
at a Kansas City game her husband's team
W and she takes a bottle of
champagne and shakes it and like sprays
it on the crowd like they do at concerts
and stuff and people are like that is
disrespectful on the crowd of people in
the stands yes okay and okay yes like
could someone make an argument like that
was kind of an annoying thing to do for
sure but like do you know football
culture people like [__] themselves cuz
they're so drunk like like really now
we're all about hygiene and cleanliness
and respecting people's boundaries like
have you seen the videos of what goes on
at football games right please that's
really where it starts from yes yes then
she made this other video she just
became kind of like a and and all in
support of her husband like she became
like kind of a really crazy fan girl so
she there was this video that had went
viral where she won a game she's in the
spee she's talking to her phone to all
the people that doubted us and hat on us
guess I can and she's like being a
little nuts and yeah like it's annoying
for sure but like leave her alone no the
more people like want to dislike her and
the more you tell me about these like
non incidents the more the more feel I
feel like I want to defend her no
same just for the sake of like Humanity
for it's the principle of the matter
exactly yeah
exactly are you ready for our next
story
yeah Justin Timberlake apologized to
quote absolutely [__] nobody before
performing CRI a river at a
concert Justin timberl celebrated his
birth timberlea celebrated his birthday
with a one night only show in New York
City and made it clear he has nobody to
apologize to the former in sync frontman
turned solo star turn 43 on Wednesday
and celebrated by playing a free show at
Irving Plaza performing both a slew of
his career spanning hits and some of his
new music Sorry before singing his hit
me a river he took a moment to share
some candid Thoughts with the crowd he
said I'd like to take this opportunity
to apologize to [__] nobody he said
before the song a concert goer confirmed
to People
magazine okay this is so layered because
I feel as though it's extremely in
congruous with his PR strategy up until
this point which has been ignorance like
ignoring this big elephant in the room
and be just like acknowledging like
there are people who hate him but there
are also people who love him and like
he's just going to make music for them
and Jessica be has been working overtime
with her eating in the shower idiocy and
she's been all over my Tik Tok like
happy anniversary like they've been
working over time so this feels like
such a diversion from that plan and I
don't know if it's the right plan
because I gen I generally love people
saying like oh there's backlash eat my
[__] ass like I love people who
ignore criticism like I'm going to do my
life internet commentary has no bearing
on my success or my happiness so I
generally love that line of
work I don't like it here I don't think
it's going to be
successful and if in fact it's very very
very likely this man has nobody to
apologize to but just saying it without
like an explanation or documentary it's
not going to compute for us why go
further why don't you want anyone an
apologize especially when the things
that are being discussed about him they
are so sensitive and the most recent is
like the abortion thing and it's just
it's just icky to be so caver c yeah
Cavalier
and like arrogant about something like
that it's better just to not mention if
you if you don't have if you're not
going to say anything that people are
going to want to hear just don't say
anything at all rather than taking this
route which it's like that's kind of
mean and the thing is you're being
you're in this position for mean
Behavior to begin
with yeah yeah like and I don't think
that ignoring it was going really well
for him either like if you open any of
his social media or any clips of an
interview like the comments it's all
about Britney there's not one I have not
heard except Ben came in he was like you
know I like that song selfish I'm like
when was the last time you heard a new
song I was shocked like that Ben had
kept up with a new song that came out in
the last five years he's like it's good
I'm like okay get out of here e uh Zach
was playing it in our house and it's not
bad and what I actually found
interesting is I find I can't enjoy his
music because I hear him too much and
like I'm just like GH I I just don't
like his his voice sorry yeah but he
didn't sound like him like I I had to
ask who is
this um yeah so he's kind of like being
stealth the thing is I feel like he's at
a point in his career where he does have
like a really loyal fan base like it's
the older women who love him from the
Instinct dates who have followed him
forever they just ride or die for him
and I think that's just like what he
needs to
nurture he's probably not going to
change any hearts and Minds unless
there's a brilliant PR strategy which I
don't even know what that would be but
what he's doing now it ain't working so
he should just like stop trying to make
he's never going to be what he was for
that period of time there was a time
where every was like he's an exyle
Jackson King of Pop y ya y Vanguard
award he's never going to be that
again so he should just like start a
patreon you know yeah I just think
either you address it or you don't and
you don't just like say things like this
that seem unkind it's true it's that's
okay let's just and I'm not even like a
kindness World kindness t sort of person
no I was actually thinking this morning
you think I'm a kindness World kindness
no I was kidding oh okay I was like have
I misr represented myself but it also
got me thinking
like I don't think it's right that world
kindness day only happens once a year
interesting how often do you think it
should happen I think it should be a
monthly occurrence well I saw that a few
weeks ago it was World compliment day so
I feel like there are these just making
[__] up there are off there offshoots of
world kindness day okay Jackie it's
World compliment day compliment
me
tury like compliment you in general or
for today a compliment of the day both
either T you're so magnetic and charming
and wonderful and everyone including
myself loves to be around
you I feel
lighter maybe every day should be World
compliment day at least here on this
show I feel like it is like every
morning I'm like you look Gorge like
it's so true we're always lifting a girl
that I love the most it's we're always
lifting each other up no we're like hype
women for one another every day is World
compliment day here at the toast
literally are you ready for our next
story which is four yeah Margot Robbie
Oh I thought you were asking like which
number no like what's the story Margo
Robbie's reacting to the the snub herd
round the world um you know what and
this is what she said because she is
gracious and normal she said there's no
way to feel sad when you know you're
this blessed she was at a screening of
um
the movie it was actually a special sag
Afra screening so that's really exciting
I've missed my dear sag Afra she you
missed your sag Afra
family I think I should join sag Afra by
the way it's literally expensive I one
time like filmed an ad that was SAG
eligible so my team was like Joan like
you just pay dues and then you get like
health insurance and it's like a good
thing to be a part of I was like okay
dues and this was a couple years ago
like actually like a a lot of years ago
three grand I was like I could just buy
health insurance with three grand like
is Sag Afra a scam like no it's not it's
not sking
SC however margar Robie made
to celebrate all the academy nominations
the film did receive saying she was
beyond ecstatic over the movie's
Collective eight nominations she said
everyone getting the nods that they've
had is just incredible and the best
picture
nod yeah like Margot Robbie if she said
anything else like this is a response
Barbie would say Barbie would be happy
for the other
Barbies yeah who got nominated and I
think people
really h i i could write a dissertation
on what Barbie did for the culture like
the movie itself and what she said she
was like how could I really be upset
like this movie was a phenomenon people
loved it it brought people together
girls got dressed up we broke records
how could I be unhappy and she's 100%
right about that I'm talking about like
what it did to like the internet users I
don't know what it was it's kind of like
Josie and the Pussycats they put
something in the Barbie movie that
subliminally messaged like people on the
internet to become mentally ill yeah but
how come you didn't fall for it I'm too
strong she's too
strong like the I and I've said we need
to start a list okay start a list start
a list okay get your phone random things
SL toopics that became polarizing for no
[__] reason o that's
fun the Barbie
movie K the topic of returning to the
office like no people were getting
cancelled for their takes on Barbie
canceled for just their opinions on the
return to work conversation which was a
conversation we were having and if
and I feel like I said one last week
remember when I said it like it's giving
Barbie the fans help what was it let me
go back to the
stories I said like the the discourse
has become like one-sided and if you
don't say the one thing you're you're
insane yeah yeah yeah okay um and it's
like it's you would think like okay
maybe sure the war in Gaza I can
understand why that would be a divisive
and polarizing
topic Barbie like for real like we need
to get a
grip list of random topics that became
polarizing guys what was it it sound off
in the comments please what was
it it was something really
random I don't think I'll see find
it no that wasn't it what the [__] was
it okay maybe someone will remember in
the comments but I want to start that
list because every now and then like
there will be a topic that'll come up in
like
in the discourse of society and for some
reason it
becomes like the most divisive and it's
like this innocuous thing you know what
I'm thinking what I'm thinking I should
watch the Barbie movie oh for sure I
love how we talk about it every day and
we're like why won't people stop talking
about it literally we won't stop talking
about it and you haven't even seen it
yeah I think for the discourse and for
the show and we keep talking about it
like I think I need to know what's going
on fun thing is like I think you would
like that the movie it's really not that
serious it's very cute it's beautifully
done it's funny it's really is funny I
giggled many times like there's like
this thing at the I feel like the end
kind of ruins you don't think I'll hate
it more than you like no cuz it's like
sweet it there's by the way and thing is
I can't stress this enough I didn't hate
the Barbie movie like I enjoyed it like
it wasn't amazing I think there were
parts of it that fell flat like it was a
good movie like I went to the movies I
like it was a fun night out with my
friend Margo like I hate like the
discourse and The Stance but the movie
itself I feel like I came on the show
like it wasn't amazing there were
cringey parts of it but like I enjoyed
it it was a movie yeah yeah okay I'm
going to watch it give me till the end
of the weekend the thing is I actually
think you would like enjoy it it's just
like a funny silly if you don't take it
so seriously like some people do yeah
cry crying about the Barbie movie okay
that'll be exciting tune in Monday I'm
going to I'm going to have my homework
done by Monday for my thoughts Ben
didn't like I'm finally weighing in Ben
didn't like it but Ben wouldn't like it
he was like the best part was will frell
and I actually thought will Farrell's
character was like so stupid me and Ben
have completely different like interests
and
uh what's word I'm looking for
different senses of
humor I think you like it it's like be
it's really beautifully done okay
visually okay this will be
fun yeah oh my God I can't wait are you
ready for our fifth and final story
about our swirly Kelly Clarkson says her
pre-diabetes diagnosis drove her to lose
weight so Kelly Clarkson's recent weight
loss was sparked by a warning from her
doctors she said I was told I was
pre-diabetic that was literally what
happened I wasn't shocked I was a tiny
bit overweight so I wasn't shocked she
explained on her show earlier this week
but they were like you're pre-diabetic
you're right on the borderline she went
on when she was speaking to her guest
Kevin James she said I was like oh she I
was I by the way Kevin James came on her
show I saw a clip and he was talking
about how he went viral
like a couple a couple months ago that
random picture of him from Kings of
Queens he was like I had no idea my
daughter showed it to me we were
cackling at some of the memes he was
like it was so funny he loved it I
posted one of them yesterday on my story
It's the funniest thing it's the
funniest
thing and it's like an old picture right
Jackie it's a thousand years old it's
from King of Queens that show hasn't
been on the air for 20 years who does
this stuff like who makes it go viral
who I don't know like taste makers I
need we need to meet them we need to
meet the person who plucked this picture
from obscurity and made it a meme it's
it's not a s it's not a group of people
that's like a true organic viral moment
like that one started with some [__]
random person finding this photo and
like maybe the Tweet got retweeted a
couple more times and inspired people to
like share their own version with the
photo it really was the most and we
don't have moments like that anymore I
feel like back in the day we had so many
organic viral moments like every single
day
that one was giving 2010 like it was
amazing no but like we have them all the
time even people who pluck like random
audios from like old reality shows and
then oh that's true they're different
now do like Tik toks of them hey how
y'all doing yeah yeah no that you're
right the format has changed but the
formula Remains the Same oh my God
that's so funny she's asking the
questions that we need to know the
answers to totally anyway she said that
that's why she was motivated to lose
weight weight because of this um
pre-diabetes diagnosis I'm like annoyed
that Kelly shared this because I feel
like it's nobody's business why someone
chooses to lose weight and I feel like
she kind of felt like she had to cuz
everyone's been talking about it so much
like oh zic it's like shut up and you
know I never like got tested but I'm
sure I was pre-diabetic like when I
first started my journey just cuz you
didn't go to the doctor like literally
stayed away like avoided like the plague
now you're like hey you guys need me for
anything and now now I'm like hey how
you how you doing you need to run a test
or something you need to get on this tap
a vein you me to get on the scale anyone
let's not let's not go crazy that was
like what we were talking about on
patreon yesterday how when you make a
doctor's appointment and then you show
up and it's like for you're like hey
it's me I'm back and they're like what's
your last name date of birth who are you
um wait back to Kelly oh I I don't
really need Kelly to address her weight
loss I feel like Kelly's been one of
those public figures and I'm sorry like
if you're just a woman a mother in the
spotlight for decades like you're going
to look different like I don't give a
[__] like shut up I really don't care I
would like her to address like what's
been going on with her style recently
because she's been looking so slay the
house down boops and Houston I'm
deceased like I need more on that well
that's why we have to get her on the
toast it's disgusting she hasn't come on
this is why we have a chip on our
shoulder
yeah Kelly Clarkson is the reason the
chip is just Kelly yeah it's a Kelly
siiz Chip she's on our shoulders cuz she
refuses to acknowledge us matter how
much praise we Heap on her year after
year yeah no it's twisted and sick and
disgusting those are the stories and as
I said very sad very sad well the show
isn't over yet because we have deer
toasters our weekly advice segments that
I feel like for the next couple of weeks
will probably be on Thursdays moving
forward because Vander pump rules now
airs on Tuesday nights Wednesdays Vander
pump rules Thursdays your toasters so if
you want to write in we have so many
submissions we're kind of like it's an
embarrassment of riches but we'll always
take more dear toasters gmail.com is
where you can send us an email we will
keep your identity Anonymous of course
write in about anything that's going on
you can also submit at the toast
podcast.com if you scroll down there's
like a little submission box that's also
Anonymous share what's going on at work
what's going on at home what's going on
with your family what going on with your
friends it's going on in your wedding
planning whatever it is the cater the
better and we'll do our best to help are
you ready
yep hi girlies first of all thank you
I'm a stay-at-home mom and you help me
get through a lot so my boys are three
and 8 months old we don't have any
family close by me so me and my husband
do not get a lot of date nights we've
invited we've been invited to a wedding
back in our home state of New York and
my parents and brother have already
offered to babysit the boys for us my
husband is already saying absolutely not
because no one ever puts our kids to
sleep besides me but I feel like this
should be my decision since I need the
night out it's already turning into a
fight is he being dramatic or am I being
unreasonable how old are the kids again
8 months old and three years old I don't
understand why he cares so much
especially if you're the one who always
puts them to sleep if you are fine with
it I'm really trying not to like jump to
divorce um because like he seems crazy
and why doesn't he ever put them to
sleep I don't no and also like not
enough people and mostly not enough
husbands understand like being a
stay-at-home mom is a privilege but also
a prison I did it for like half a day
and I you were there it was horrible it
was so horrible I I think I slept for
like six hours like I was not
okay it's really it's it's one of those
situations where it's like seems
innocuous like yeah we'll miss the
wedding whatever I'm thinking divorce I
just don't understand his reason because
they only get put down by you okay so is
that going to be your life for the next
18 years like at some point he's
obviously like very controlling honestly
he sounds really
controlling you have to go to the
sweating oh you have to go to the
sweating yeah so go by yourself say you
know what they need a parent to put them
down you should stay back I'll go love
I'll take my brother as my date since
he's so generous I'll meet someone else
love you have to go to this wedding like
first of all I think if you don't it
sets a really bad precedent uhhuh and
you need it like being a stay-at home
mom is so hard that's really crazy it's
crazy it's giving like Looney it's
giving controlling it's giving red flag
yeah especially they're going to be put
down by loved ones
like No And it's like they're fine
they're fine they're going to sleep yeah
and you could even like get ready for
the big event by having him put them
down sometimes so they could realize no
it's out of state it's out of state I
think it's like a weekend no but until
that weekend why doesn't oh dad put them
down sometimes so they know oh someone
other than Mom can put us down love yeah
love
no no you have like it is of the utmost
importance that you go to this wedding
for the sake of your marriage for the
sake of your mental health and for your
children yeah you have to go I'll be mad
at you if you don't
go all right now let's help out one of
our jenzy toasters okay they need us
desperately hey girls I'm in high school
I'm trying really hard to move on from a
boy and I need advice let me try to sum
it up quickly we've been an item on and
off since the end of sophomore year to
my senior year but we could never make
it work when school school started this
year we both made it on the home coming
court and I called dibs on walking with
him I thought it was the perfect I
thought it was perfect and then I heard
that he told girls in my grade that he
wanted to walk with a different girl the
dance went terrible he was cold to me
the entire time and I went home crying
the next week I found out he's already
planning to go to prom with one of his
girl friends friends that's a girl she
put a space a space between them he will
still Snapchat me and text me and then
when I respond he will just leave me on
red after a talk with my mom I decided
to stop responding as much but
apparently he didn't like that and
stopped talking to me alt together
together we haven't talked since but I'm
crushed because he seems like such a
different person this year hanging out
with me and girls partying he's planning
on drinking how do I move on G you have
to cold turkey like goodbye good riddens
I hate him he's like I hate everything
that he's doing and what's good is like
you were off and on for two years and
you couldn't make it work which means
you can look back at the past and like
try and take off rosecolor glasses even
if he were responding to you and like
wanting to do stuff with you it still
wouldn't be good you guys it's not like
you were solid and those were the best
two years of your life it didn't work
for a reason you need it and also this
is going to be the best for you and also
what will actually get at him and yeah
and be successful so it's the perfect
ignore he doesn't exist no more
Snapchatting no more texting don't even
look at him move on completely no and by
the way once you do that like he will
come back to you and I will kill you
with my own two hands if you go back to
him but also like and I just I feel like
you're in such an important time in your
life right now like what month is it
February oh my God you have like three
more months of your senior year of high
school the next three months are about
to be like the best of your life it all
goes downhill after that like you are
about to enter about to enter the
Pinnacle of adolescence and if you spend
those three months pining after a little
piece of [__] like I will kill you I
will personally come to your hometown
and I will kill you spend it with
friends meet new people fall in love
with someone else in the grand scheme of
your life and I know like you can't see
out of it right now but if you zoomed
out like this person will not even be a
blimp on your radar he will be so
irrelevant you will not be telling your
grandchildren about this person like
move on immediately hang out with your
friends meet new people give someone
else a chance if you the energy you put
out is what people are going to give to
you so you're giving off closed off
energy because you're obsessed with this
guy who's mean to you like open yourself
up to new energy to receiving new
friendships new relationships this is
I'm so jealous of the three months
you're about to have like prom senior
prank whatever it is they do with
schools these days like you're about to
have the time of your life like I'm so
jealous if I could go back to February
AR of my senior year like there's so
much I would tell myself first of all I
would say like you're not fat like you
think you're fat but you're not you're
not you're beautiful like stop putting
on so much makeup you don't need that
much
eyeliner maybe brush your hair that's
what I would say just enjoy enjoy you
will be mad at yourself if you spend
this time like if you let this person
ruin this magical time in your life no
starting right now no more texting no
more Snapchatting he doesn't exist you
cannot give him another thought you're
going to find a different promt date
like it's over no more it you'll find
another prompt date you obviously listen
to the show which means you're stunning
and it won't be hard for you at even if
you even if you don't agree with us try
it our way for a month and he will come
around too like that's the thing about
this strategy is that it's also going to
like bring him back to but if you commit
to it you'll realize that you don't even
want him around Jackie's right give it a
month and you will find naturally you
stop thinking about him you start
enjoying things more because you're not
checking your phone to see if he
responded to you st off your phone as
much as you can it's good for your brain
give him nothing nothing oh my please
write me back at the end of the year I
want to know how your senior year goes
this is like the most important thing in
me and I'm going to write a young adult
novel about it love it give him nothing
that's the advice and you absolutely
have to follow it there's no like
sometimes we're like take it or leave it
we demand sometimes we say take it or
leave it here no you must follow
this
we require it mhm our third and final
deer toaster is one of my favorite types
of deer toaster it's a religion
one hello my beautiful stunning and
smart girlies I love you both dearly my
brother is getting married in April to
an absolute precious gem of a woman and
he has an idea that I'm not so sure
about he really wants to do the horor
during his reception the problem is is
we are not Jewish and his fiance's
family is not Jewish either he asked one
of his Jewish friends who said it would
be fine but I would be remiss devastated
and heartbroken if I didn't ask my
Jewish Queens for their opinions my
brother is truly a wild card in a good
way so it would be on brand for him to
do something unexpected I know he's
coming from a good place and he just
really loves the fun tradition but is
doing the horror at a non-jewish wedding
problematic signed the respectful sister
of a non-jewish groom no I think it's so
cute feel free to appropriate Jewish
culture all you want as long as you
support Israel it's so true like what
what sort of um what sort of
conversations are you having about
what's going on in Israel like you can't
you can't join Judaism when it's fun and
then not stand up for us when it gets
hard so agreed 1,00% but I think it's I
think it's fine and you know what that's
I have always said I would say I've
probably been to like three non-jewish
weddings in my entire life and I've
probably been to a hundred weddings and
I think Jewish weddings are the best
like they're so fun they're so
meaningful and the horror is such an
important part of it and I love that
other people see that yeah and I I could
understand why you want a piece of it
and you can make it your own and really
there's no rules and I don't think that
it's weird or anything but as I said I
don't think she's weird I think she just
just want to be disrespectful I don't
feel disrespected unless you're not
supporting Israel then I feel
disrespected so yeah we're good no it's
a it's a really good point yeah you want
all you're either with us you're either
with us or against us right that's how I
feel so if you're with us yeah feel free
love and mael talk to your brother mles
oh and he also of course has to support
to Israel as well yeah like the whole
the whole wedding party the whole anyone
getting up and you know hoisting a chair
a brief check of their social media and
they can go
1,000% as long as whoever is walking
through the door of the wedding just
RSVPs just check them quick yeah yeah
that is deer toasters again deer
toasters gmail.com is where you can
submit tomorrow's our final episode of
the week I hope you've been preparing
your Queenie and your weenie I haven't
been me neither I need to really sit and
think long and hard about it I feel like
I always kind of improv just based on
how the episode goes but I'm going to
put thought into it I want to be
prepared yeah yeah yeah because the
weenie doesn't come so naturally to
me oh I mean we've spoken at length
about how we're so different in that way
right so I'm going to I'm going to look
at the week out of glance also you guys
exciting I know this episode is over oh
yeah this episode is over sad sad but
the redheads is out today when I climb
to bed I start feeling sad Jackie say
the episode's over today's episode of
the toast is
ending
but there's a new episode of the
redheads
out and it's really great stuff so go
check it out thank you guys so much for
listening to the
toast the melano morning show where we
deliver the fast SI stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's Spotify
iTunes Stitch public radio I Radio cast
box all the places web you listen to
podcast find us toast a five star riew
about how beautiful about how stunning
about how wickedly talented we are hope
you guys have an
amazing and we'll see you tomorrow
for Friday day of
fry we'll see you tomorrow for the fifth
and final day of the week of the work
week love you bye love you
bye